I would first
show you this thing it's a it's this
constructor's helmet is one of the
symbols of recent
anti-dictatorship protests in Ukraine it
was supposed to protect your head from
police sticks or if you were lucky
enough from rubber bullets
of course later on helmets like this
would not protect people from snipers
and from gunmen and as you know more
than 100 of protesters died in the
streets of Kiev mostly because of the
sniper's bullets and because of police
grenades
but if well I have brought this helmet
here and just to remind all of us that
there are countries where people
literally fight and die for their right
to live under democracy
and if you talked to my brothers on the
barricades they would be very surprised
to hear this kind of
discussion democracy for them means that
no one can govern people without their
consent
democracy for them it's their right to
be responsible for their future so
people those angry men who were wearing
orange helmets orange Constructors
helmets they were literally feeling
themselves felt themselves as
Constructors of their future this is
what democracy is about for them it's a
very clear moral choice it's a choice
between freedom and slavery between hope
and humiliation that's what democracy is
about for them and I think we should
really keep that in mind before we go
into some more pragmatic things to
discuss
now let's do some numbers and let's talk
pragmatically here's the World list of
the richest countries by the per capita
income in 2012 only four out of top 20
countries were not democracies only six
out of top 30 countries were not
democracies
and there is a clear evidence of a
correlation between democracy and
economic development and we perfectly
understand why true not all democracies
are rich in fact some democracies are
miserably poor but if you build a stable
democracy you have better chances to be
rich and to live in a prosperous Society
we understand why because democracy also
means rule of law freedom of
Entrepreneurship more democracy
generally means more prosperity
here is the United Nations human
development index list of 2013 and it's
even more interesting for us because
this index is based on three criteria
it's life expectancy its education and
it's the per capita income which we have
just discussed
so the Premier League of the list is
called the countries with very high
human development only 3 out of 47
countries on the list are not
democracies
and that makes sense because democracy
means that you spend wealth National
wealth not just for fancy palaces or
luxury cars for the few who are in power
but you've got to take care of the
constituents
when you cast your vote in the end of
this debate
I really ask you to think about the rest
of the world when you will be making a
decision please cast a vote on behalf of
protesters in Venezuela on behalf of
civil activists in Iran on behalf of all
those people who know they will not be
able to enjoy the Privileges of
democracy you enjoy by the end of their
lives that's the reason why they are
ready to fight for that that's the
reason why they are ready to fight and
probably die to give the chance to their
kids and to their grandchildren so
please do think about the ukrainians who
have been have been fighting for freedom
of their country for its territorial
integrity and for the better world for
all of all of us so please vote against
the motion and in favor of democracy
thank you very much indeed and for being
here from Kiev now we've heard from the
four speakers four and against the
motion
before I hear from you in the audience
with the microphones I'm going to give
you the result of what you decided as
you were coming in not having listened
to any of the debates so far let me tell
you that almost half of you had not made
up your minds uh 44 of you don't know uh
what your view is are on this motion
democracy is not always the best form of
government but 38 of you did think that
you were for the motion and 18 were
against so there's a lot of work to be
done on both sides here to convince you
let's hear from you please stand up
could I get a lady there and a lady
somewhere in the middle there please
hello this is
in
you gave a lot of examples and
you'll see and democracies that are
flawed I was wondering whether you could
give us an example of a good democracy
as if that's something that we all
should be working towards it would be
good to have a role model
stack that up in uh there's at the back
please you've got the microphone and
then move the microphone down here
please to the gentleman here
but have a definition of what democracy
is if it's about voting then and for
Representatives we have a 55 percent
unelected legislator here in the UK the
House of Lords and the queen are we a
democracy also for turnout rates
particularly among young people about 30
percent of the last general election are
15 of the last European election is this
a democracy thank you Luke
at the back at the back there please I
am against the motion and for democracy
and I think that Ian Brenner had really
good points
um yeah he's a very good speaker as well
but um I think that a very important
point a very important point he made was
that it isn't the question really isn't
whether democracy is or isn't the best
form of government but it's about
accountability
and that is something that I think we're
kind of missing the points and it's
democracy in many countries countries
can be poor and Democratic and Rich and
Democratic it doesn't mean that
democracy is always
being like um practiced but it is the
best form right so the issue about
definition of democracy which we could
debate all night but um Andrei when you
look at what you've been through what
you're still going through and what
still lies ahead in your country do you
have a clarity about what democracy is
I think what we might think about is we
can explore some new opportunities of
democracy I think it would be ridiculous
to limit democracy just to
representative democracy or in the
classic meaning think about Iceland
after it went through this terrible
financial crisis they had a
constitutional assembly it wasn't
elected in the classical way but when
people represented fishermen teachers
whoever get together get together if I
may say so in other words democracy is
everything that makes you feel good
democracy is something that the lady was
talking about it's really about feeling
accountable
I would think it I would say it would be
ridiculous to limit democracy just to
mathematics and to devote count that's
my point but going back to Iceland so
when they got together when they were
rewriting the constitution of this
country one of the first thing which was
in the document was we are supposed to
protect the Earth
is probably something which the which
typical politicians would not think
about in the beginning of the
Constitution so I think new forms of
democracy could provide us with some
great new forms of governing but it's
it's not to undermine the basic
principles we're talking about
I said at the beginning uh government
for the People by the people yeah you
have Queen it's true do I think that
really impinges on representative
democracy in Britain the House of Lords
I mean it costs you some money but
fundamentally speaking no
um there's a spectrum here look China is
more democratic than North Korea right
do we think China is more generally
respectful of civil rights to North
Korea yeah
um who's farther along that Spectrum
India is more democratic than China is
do we think India is more respectful of
Human Rights generally speaking than
China and I think the answer is yeah
um are there any well-run democracies
out there look Canada
's today Canada's Canada is pretty well
run the Scandinavians the more Democrat
the Scandinavians are more well-run than
the United States absolutely uh I think
I'd say Australia on balance is more
wrong they're smaller it's easier so now
efficiency that's part of the definition
excuse me efficiency well run
well run as part of the of being a
democracy no no I didn't say that at all
you said they were better for
democracies because they were well run
what does that means better democracies
in the sense that they are they are
governments that are more effectively
run for and by the people they are more
legitimate and seen as more legitimate
the as I mentioned the United States has
a more difficult time today because the
the the the
um the state has been captured to a
degree by the private sector in a way
that has not in Canada that absolutely
undermines the ability of the American
government to be seen as governed by and
forth so your argument does basically
rest on ideals not realities
no I wouldn't say that at all
but democracy is certainly democracy
absolutely takes into into consideration
the ideals of the people of the country
well I mean you know I I
know beyond the point what your argument
is because it seems to be everything now
let's take the example of China okay
compared with any Western Country at the
moment and you look at the Pew Global
attitude survey statistics and the
levels of satisfaction uh amongst the
Chinese with what's going to happen to
their standard of living the economic
competence of the government and their
Outlook in terms of what the future is
going to bring is way higher than it is
in Western societies
and it's not true that um you know
democracy is a by and large better run
than thing than things that in our book
like China aren't democracies although
of course they do have elements of
democracy
[Applause]